البحرية الأمريكية في
طريقها إلى عمق ما تعتبره روسيا في
فنائها الخلفي ،
نحن على متن طائرة حربية بحرية
وطائرة مراقبة من طراز P8
في البحر الأسود ، إنها منطقة ذات تسليح شديد
وقد أخبرنا أن الطائرات الروسية تحلق في
الجو وأن الطاقم يرصد أحدهم يزحف  إنها
طائرة مقاتلة من طراز Su-27 يبدو أنها تتحرك بعيدًا عن
متناول اليد
ولكن فجأة انطلقت طائرتنا
بسرعة عندما اصطدمنا بالمقاتل تمامًا كما هو الحال مع
انسحابه ،
فقد يكون طيارًا غير متوقع ربما
طيارًا جديدًا أو شيء من هذا القبيل
لذلك يمكن  دائمًا ما يكون تحديًا
نبقى في حالة تأهب دائم عندما يتم
اعتراضنا ، يتتبع الطاقم العديد من
الطائرات الروسية الأخرى القريبة
مثل هذه المواجهة مع
الطائرات الحربية الروسية ليست غير شائعة بالنسبة لنا نحن
العسكريين الذين
نطير في أماكن مثل البحر الأسود في
الواقع نحن  يقول الجيش
إنهم أصبحوا أكثر شيوعًا ، كما أن
بعضهم
يتم إجراؤه بطريقة غير آمنة في
أواخر أغسطس ، صدم اثنان من
المعترضين الروس بطائرة B-52
تعمل هنا وماذا  تقول الولايات المتحدة إنه كان
اعتراضًا غير آمن ،
وتقول روسيا إنها كانت تعمل
وفقًا للمعايير الدولية ، لكن ليس هناك
شك في أن
موسكو أصبحت أكثر جرأة في عام 2017 ،
حلقت الطائرات الروسية بسفينة
حربية أمريكية في البحر الأسود ، وفي
الآونة الأخيرة فقط في سوريا
صدمت المركبات العسكرية الروسية
القافلة الأمريكية
الرئيس ترامب  لم ينادي
علنًا فلاديمير بوتين بسلسلة
الحوادث الأخيرة بيننا وبين القوات الروسية ،
لكنه استمر في الإصرار على أنه صارم مع
روسيا ،
فأنا
أتفق مع الرئيس بوتين ، لكني كنت أكثر صرامة مع
روسيا من أي شخص آخر
بكلمات بعيدة  لا يبدو أنه ردع
موسكو وجودها في المنطقة الذي
زاد خلال السنوات الماضية تحلق طائرة P-8
مباشرة إلى عرين الأسد
قبالة ميناء سيفاستوبول البحري الرئيسي في روسيا
على البحر الأسود في شبه جزيرة القرم ، حيث
تعقب الطاقم 10
سفن عسكرية روسية في مكان قريب
بما في ذلك  هذه
الغواصة من فئة الكيلوغرامات قبل التحقق من
المدمرة الأمريكية روزفلت والتي كانت
تحجبها أيضًا سفينة حربية روسية
نصحك بأن لديك جهة اتصال خدمة
لتكون مقاتلًا يتتبعك
بالتوازي على بعد
ستة أميال تقريبًا من المروحية الجانبية اليمنى ،
إنها حقًا رسالة إلى جميع
الخصوم
المحتملين ورسالتنا إلى حلفائنا
وشركائنا
بأننا هنا لدعمهم.  الحرية
والازدهار مفتوحان لكامل قارة
أوروبا وهذا يشمل البعثات في
المناطق الصعبة والمتنازع عليها مثل
البحر الأسود
حيث تواصل روسيا محاولة تنمية
نفوذها في البحر الأسود.